as keeping a vaccine this ends with na
na hoti cat and on drona non-gang met
resolution on Meatwad 'as to taken again
with no electromobility
game yep
[Music]
the battery-powered Johanna j-1 started
out as a pet project something a small
team of Austrian engineers worked on
during evenings and weekends
for six years they've sold 60 bikes
across Europe since launching in 2014
with almost everything built and
designed in-house the electric bike
market is really starting to heat up
since the entry of makers like victory
and zero gadot hammer sees more of
itself in Tesla this is thus as a Tesla
all the year they get stuck it's only
capital as a test lasts a day off
intelligent mobility antenna keepo
doctor
that's care to salmon
[Music]
I've been riding motorbikes for more
than 20 years I owned seven of them but
this is my first green ride and I don't
know how I'll feel without a rumbling
engine under me I'm taking the j1 for a
cruise through its natural environment
the mountainous region of Austria along
the Czech border there's something raw
and emotional about the sound and smell
of a conventional motorbike but at
cruising speeds you can hardly hear the
j1 at all it's like comparing a
motorboat in a sailboat and that goes
for the experience - without the grunt
the trip feels more leisurely and
relaxing
along these winding roads the j1 has a
range of 124 miles and that jumps to 186
on city streets that's a big achievement
for Evite's
remember though this is a cruiser not a
racer and its speed limited to just
under 80 miles per hour
there is no dash board instead all the
instrumentation is displayed in the to
revision mirrors the top spec Jay bond
cost just under $27,000 slightly more
than its competitors it's aimed at
pleasure-seeking riders who are
entrepreneurial and design conscious
[Music]
it's got a lot of really really clever
technology if I twist the throttle the
other way it slows down very quickly and
the electric drive motor turns into a
generator humming electricity back into
the lithium-ion battery a full recharge
from a domestic outlet takes three and a
half hours that's reduced to 18 minutes
using a higher amperage connection but
yo Hamill wants to push the battery
technology even further there's also a
plan or already a prototype running in
Switzerland where you can use your
hammers external energy storage so
someday soon your motorbike could be
powering your home but for me this one's
too fun
to rock
[Music]